[Musique]
bonjour à tous il n'est jamais trop tard
pour vous souhaiter une excellente année
2010 8 qu'elle soit ensoleillé avec ou
sans panneaux photovoltaïques
paris-saclay tv vous emmène aujourd'hui
ali pvf l'institut photovoltaïque et
d'île de france
ici des centaines de chercheurs venus du
monde entier planchent sur cette énergie
solaire nous irons aussi à l'institut de
mathématiques d'orsay
ce tout nouveau bâtiment de l'université
paris sud a accueilli la cérémonie de
voeux de le pea pas il s'appelait que
faut-il en retenir la réponse dans un
instant enfin une chose est sûre 2018
sera design votre territoire a désormais
un lieu consacré dédiée à cette activité
de création
le design spot l'objectif est de
permettre aux scientifiques aux
chercheurs aux étudiants de profiter une
expérience design et de recentrer leurs
travaux sur l'utilisateur et justement
des étudiants ont pu présenter leur
projet au grand public
ils ont exposé leurs oeuvres au croteau
204 rencontre avec celle qui a initié
ces expositions éphémères sarat dillies
allawi enfin d'autres événements se
profile
vous saurez tout en regardant notre
agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
bien sûr nous voici donc à l'ispm
l'institut photovoltaïque d'île de
france nous avons quitté la terrasse
pour l'atrium un tout jeune institut
mais déjà de grandes ambitions devenir
l'un des cinq plus grands centres
mondiaux de recherche sur les
dispositifs solaires photovoltaïques de
nouvelle génération
les dizaines de chercheurs sont déjà à
pied d'oeuvre tout de suite les
précisions de bruno carlotti directeur
général délégué de l'updf
[Musique]
l'institut photovoltaïque d'île de
france c'est un tout jeune institut
puisqu'il a été créé à peine trois ans
avec comme ambition que d'agréger et de
fédérer les efforts de recherche de ses
partenaires dans le domaine des cellules
photovoltaïques avec mon ambition d'
activer des leviers de partage des coûts
de la recherche et des leviers de
développement de l'innovation en
regroupant dans un même mieux des
chercheurs de culture et de savoir faire
différent donc l'objectif de l'institut
et de développer les cellules
photovoltaïques de demain laissez nous
travailler sur l'amélioration de leur
performance les rendements leur capacité
à transformer l'énergie du soleil en
électricité est également de réduire
leurs coûts de façon à poursuivre les
efforts qui ont été faits jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en termes de compétitivité
de cette filière de production mais de
rendre encore moins cher les panneaux
photovoltaïques convient juste de
regrouper ici au coeur du campus de
paris saclay a pas d eau dans ce nouveau
bâtiment que nous venons de réceptionner
une centaine de chercheurs demain sans
doute deux sens et qui vont travailler
ensemble dans un même programme de
recherche qui vise à développer ces
cellules de rupture est partenaire de
l'ipb f sont edf et total
le cnrs l'école polytechnique associé à
air liquide et puis deux équipementiers
du domaine photovoltaïque horiba et
riber est donc on retrouve la plupart de
ses partenaires sur le campus de paris
saclay et notre présence ici à apa
réseau va permettre d'amplifier
nos collaborations avec ses partenaires
avec des échanges de chercheurs d
partage d'équipements de recherche sur
le campus au tibet vf souhaite élargir
son partenariat de nouveaux acteurs
qu'ils soient locaux nationaux ou
internationaux
les avants d'ailleurs réservé une partie
du bâtiment à ces nouveaux entrants de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent venir en tant
que chercheur ou même venir avec des
équipements de recherche puisqu'on a
réservé une partie de nos laboratoires à
ses nouveaux partenaires de façon à ce
qu'ils puissent venir contribuer à la
réalisation de notre programme de
recherche et les accélérer
comme promis je vous emmène à présent à
l'institut de mathématiques dort c'est
un tout nouveau bâtiment inauguré en
octobre dernier par le président de la
république c'est ici que s'est déroulée
la cérémonie des voeux de le paix à
paris saclay les principaux acteurs du
territoire étaient présents à commencer
par le directeur général de l'opéra
paris saclay lee 22 mal la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
qui est aussi la présidente du conseil
d'administration
le pea paris saclay et sans oublier
michel cadot préfet de la région ile de
france et préfet de paris paris saclay
tv revient sur les grands moments de
cette soirée
[Musique]
m
je voudrais vous remercier aussi non
seulement d'être là de nous avoir
choisis pour faire vos voeux c'est comme
je les dis beaucoup d'honneur mais aussi
de votre soutien aussi bien au niveau de
le pap est ce qui est un accompagnateur
un allié et extraordinaire de tous qui
aménagements mais aussi au niveau de
l'université paris-sud sur tous les
projets immobiliers et nous en avons de
nombreux qui nous accompagne
efficacement
donc merci beaucoup au quotidien
accompagner ce grand défi pour la france
c'est pour nous a loupé à paris saclay
avant tout un travail collaboratif un
travail collectif
une écoute active une implication
permanente auprès de tous les nombreux
acteurs institutionnels et
universitaires économiques agricoles
environnementaux associatif et riverains
pour l'état l'essence même du projet de
paris-saclay recouvre plusieurs
ambitions dont trois à mes yeux sont
essentiels l'ambition d'être un grand
centre mondial universitaire et
scientifique
l'ambition structure et de développer
avec le monde économique 1 kloster de
l'innovation de premier plan à
l'international et l'ambition de
déployer tous projets dans un territoire
durable et résilient au total l'état et
ses établissements auront ainsi
consacrer un milliard 600 millions
d'euros
l'année 2010 est nous a confirmé que le
plateau de paris saclay a bel et bien
vocation à être à la fois un pôle
d'excellence moderne un cluster
attractif un campus écologique et
solidaire mais aussi un territoire clé
de la région métropole avec 65 mille
étudiants 6000 doctorants 9000 chercheur
et professeur à l'université paris
saclay constitue déjà le troisième lieu
où se recrutent et le plus d'ingénieurs
et de manager en france est derrière
paris intra muros est évidemment si on
prend la puissance de paris plus la
puissance de saclay
nous sommes la silicon valley européenne
d'ores et déjà je tenais à être ce soir
au moment de cet échange de voeux en
tant que préfet de cette région pour
vous faire comprendre que le soutien et
la présence et la proximité de l'état au
travers de son représentant dans le
territoire de ses représentants du
territoire vous et à qui il me semble
que le bilan qui a été présenté sur
l'allier l'année 2010 est en attestent
j'en tire la conclusion que nous entrons
effectivement dans une nouvelle étape ça
a été très bien dit les aussi bien par
directeur général que par la présidente
c'est une étape nouvelle pour l'état
pour la france pour notre pays dans le
monde ce qui se fait ici à paris saclay
est essentielle
[Musique]
je vous le disais il ya un instant 2018
sera l'année du design votre territoire
accueille un tout nouveau lieu dédié à
cette activité et de créations de
designers spot un centre ouvert à tous
les établissements du plateau aux
scientifiques aux chercheurs aux
étudiants
pourquoi dans quel but nous sommes allés
poser la question au directeur du lieu
vincent créances
[Musique]
le design spot est né de la volonté de
l'université paris saclay de constituer
un centre de design qui est vu comme un
centre de ressources à disposition des
établissements qui sont présents sur le
plateau de saclay alors ces
établissements sont de plusieurs ordres
ça peut être des labos de recherche a
peut être les filières entrepreneurial
des écoles ça peut même aussi être des
incubateurs ou des accélérateurs et
l'idée est de permettre à ces
établissements donc de profiter d'une
expérience design de façon à enrichir en
quelque sorte leur projet de recherche
d'un projet de développement avec un
regard qui est un petit peu différent de
celui qui est porté habituellement par
les scientifiques sur leurs projets donc
c'est une volonté d'élargissement c'est
une volonté aussi de d'essayer de faire
en sorte que
le design amène un mode de pensée
différents en matière de projets de
recherche un mode de pensée qui est
principalement centrée sur les
utilisateurs qui sont parfois un peu
oubliée par les chercheurs
quand ils sont consacrés à développer
énormément d'énergie à la résolution
technique ou scientifique de leur sujet
voilà nous notre but c'est d'essayer de
ne pas perdre de vue le consommateur et
quand on ne perd pas de vue le
consommateur on ne perd pas de vue non
plus les applications réelles commercial
fierais éventuelle de c2c rechercher les
actions du centre de design du design
spots sont articulées autour de trois
axes principaux le premier c'est de
faire rentrer design dans les projets de
recherche comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure et le deuxième axe c'est la
sensibilisation de façon à inciter les
chercheurs à avoir recours aux
disciplines du design et celle
sensibilisation elle consiste à
expliquer le mieux possible et plus
clairement possible
quelles sont les vertus du design les
plus values de 2 ses disciplines
un troisième axe existe également pour
le design spot c'est la recherche de
façon à faire progresser cette
discipline recherche qui peut être
établi sur le design et même ou par le
design mais toujours avec la volonté de
faire en sorte que cette discipline soit
de plus en plus efficaces
j'ai pour ma part la conviction que
réunir science & design assez réunir le
meilleur de la société de demain c'est à
dire à la fois une approche scientifique
mais aussi une approche qui est centré
sur l'humain plus émotionnelle
plus empathique mais néanmoins
toujours connectée également au marché
et oui montrer au grand public ce qu'on
a conçu dans son laboratoire finalement
c'est un test crucial
les étudiants des masters ou direction'
et human computer interaction design ont
joué le jeu ils ont exposé leur projet
ici au proto 204 rencontre avec celle
qui a lancé ses expositions éphémères
la maître de conférences sarraf 10 à 11
[Musique]
c'est le project the beaches des
étudiants en master m1 et m2 et qui a
multiplié traction et 2ème de
l'interaction de l'université paris
saclay est ici présente les travaux
qu'ils ont fait pour les cours de
creative design des shows fabrication
fabrication numérique mixte angie borie
aletti et design project
donc ce sont des projets qui sont
créatifs ce sont des projets où les
étudiants s'exprime au travers du médium
qui est l'interaction et détecter les
nouvelles technologies c'est des projets
qui sont innovants et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on les pousse à participer
à cette exposition et à confronter leurs
idées à du vrai public et à voir un peu
comment est ce qu ils peuvent affecter
les gens à travers les travaux qu'ils
ont fait et donc c'est à chaque fois un
grand plaisir d'accueillir du public et
de vous voir comment est-ce que les gens
interagissent avec les étudiants leur
donne des feedback sur leurs projets
c'est aussi une innovation pédagogique
puisque c'est à travers cette exposition
là qu'on évalue les projets des
étudiants et on considère qu'un projet
n'est pas boutique lorsqu'il est capable
de confronter à un public réel et de
vraiment existé dans la vraie vie ce
sont des étudiants qui viennent de
partout dans le monde
il ya des étudiants français notamment
dans le m2 interactions les master m1 et
m2 h ces idées font partie de l'élite et
digital qui est un ensemble de ne
heurter un qui délivre ce master là et
qui est financé par l'union européenne
les étudiants passent une année chez
nous et une année dans un autre noeud
qui peut être avec simply madrid berlin
de soute la spécificité de cette année
c'est qu'on l'a organisée au proto 204
on est très contents d'être là puisque
c'est vraiment un lieu de rencontre et
un lieu ouvert à la communauté aux
chercheurs aux étudiants aux différentes
personnes qui constituent paris saclay
on voulait le faire ici aussi pour
pouvoir ouvrir justement cette
exposition un plus large public et faire
rencontrer des étudiants différentes
filières différentes personnes qui sont
partis de paris saclay différents
laboratoires même de voir même des
entreprises du plateau et on sent que
tout ça a pris et que justement on a pu
être mobilisé 1
plus de gens de l'extérieur et que nous
mêmes on est sorti de notre laboratoire
on est allé présenter nos travaux à
l'extérieur de notre chez nous quoi donc
on est très très contente de ça et
maintenant notre agenda du 22 février au
2 mars
ne ratez pas ce workshop concours qui
nous invite à imaginer le paysage
énergétique du futur du plateau de paris
saclay c'est à centrale supélec
enfin c'est aussi à centrale supélec que
se tiendra la journée de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
venez rencontrer les jeunes
entrepreneurs de l'université paris
saclay découvrir leurs idées leurs
réussites participer pourquoi pas à leur
aventure
voilà c'est la fin de cet agenda et
c'est la fin de ce numéro de paris
saclay tv vous donne rendez vous très
vite
d'ici là restez informé sur notre site
au pap est ce point fr / tv 78 et bien
sûr sur tous nos réseaux sociaux à très
bientôt
[Musique]